salut c'est jimmy et je suis content de
vous retrouver ici j'espère que tout va
bien de votre côté aujourd'hui d'en
confier d'ici et d'ailleurs je vous
emmène à la découverte de maïs mais
trail burgart il s'agit d'un jeune chef
cuisinier martiniquais qui travaille aux
états unis saluent mike merci de nous
accueillir chez toi en arizona c'est ça
c'est ça on n'est pas un phénix alors
comment un martiniquais se retrouve aux
états unis anciennement qu'il soit
j'étais les chefs au fort de france et
les gens rencontrés les américains des
restaurateurs document proposait une
opportunité
quelques semaines après j'étais là-bas
pour visiter je suis jamais parti
j'étais chef à new york et le plusieurs
établissements et puis avec tout ce qui
se passe en ce moment l'économie
particulièrement la restauration à new
york et de catastrophique donc j'ai les
grêlons on arrive donc à quitter new
york pour aller en arizona parce que
là-bas y avait plus d'activité il n'y
avait plus rien en fait j'ai eu un
message d'un ami pour le gouverneur nous
a averti un peu à l'avant savons les
informations les journalistes en parlant
de ça et donc il était proche du gardien
il a expliqué que vous allez bientôt
fermer la ville et puis on est passé en
quarantaine et c'était donc à ce moment
là j'ai décidé de bouger et mon ami de
la zone à on est parti on est parti à sa
famille ducrocq et on a un style quel
type de cuisine tu fais à new york est
ce que c'est de la cuisine antillaise
que tu proposes est-ce que ça un mix des
deux est-ce que tu arrives à faire
découvrir aux new yorkais quand tu y
étais en tout cas des saveurs du pays
des des plats du pays c'est très
intéressante parce que la carte que j'ai
joué à 1 heure ou différencier c'est
justement cette carte de ce qu'ils
appellent french qui arrivent et ils ont
jamais entendu parler de ça ils
connaissent caribéen ménages américains
s'est excusé le dessus d'un caribou et
au final proposer une cuisine comme ça
que je faisais à fort de france pour
cuisine métissée
je sais moi je suis métisse et avec des
aspirations français cet ancien et
martiniquaise c'est quelque chose qu'ils
ont qu'ils ont jamais vu donc ça les
intéressait et les mutants le resteront
dans lequel je travaille et je faisais
cuse héniart et de colombo avec toi et
je veux c'est que je fais après aussi et
faire des courses à new york et ben
c'est simple puisque murs et une ville
haute à thème nous dresserons mais
personne pour poser sa et que c'est ce
qui est plus très très bonne idée on que
sarah mènera du monde aux antilles
peut-être grâce à ta cuisine pourront se
dire bah tiens il ya la martinique il ya
pas que la jamaïque a pas que la barbade
ya aussi la martinique avec des
spécificités une culture culinaire
notamment et ce sera peut-être après ce
confinement bien évidemment l'occasion
de devoir encore plus d'américains et de
new york et débarquer chez nous en
arizona tu as pu trouver un restaurant
ou pas les répétitions du souk à new
york à quoi la quarantaine donc pour des
raisons qui sont ouverts la plupart sont
vécus l'an en livraison s'est emporté ce
monde peut pas par exemple des généreux
thinel dans un et sont donc je suis en
train d'explorer la piste là à ce moment
pour être sincère du vu la conjoncture
actuelle c'est vraiment trop à boulon
jusqu'au quai des actuaires est ce que
tout le monde fait puisque beaucoup de
coeur personnes ont perdu leur emploi
donc c'est vraiment trouver d'abord un
job et puis après créer quelque chose ou
regarder quoi un autre restaurant dans
lequel je pourrais éventuellement
reproduire cette cuisine
quand on bosse en cuisine etc employés
chef en plus on a beaucoup de gens
autour de soi d'économie et tout ça
c'est pas toujours évident pour des gens
qui ne parlent pas français d'expliquer
ce qu'ils veulent exactement est ce que
tu as été confronté à cette barrière de
la langue ou est ce que tu es polyglotte
et que tu parle anglais couramment
en fait j'ai appris j'ai appris
l'anglais coach si pour vous le savez la
suisse chez ma soeur qui à notre service
donc du coup la lombalgie c'était
l'anglais est un petit peu l'allemand
est aussi j'appelle espagnols dont
j'étais au collège au lycée est en fait
tout seul rixe comme tu dis à beaucoup
de personnes en cuisine je suis à des
mexicains tu as déjà mais qu'un tiens
j'ai rien de tout est bon on ait avis
évidemment l'anglais comme langue donc
on n'avait pas trop de mal à ce qu'ils
font et pour ceux qui parlent espagnol
je perdais espagne je suis avec eux mais
au début c'est beaucoup de jeunes
s'étaient dissipées mais non c'est un
plat de maintenant je vais vraiment
j'avais très bonne équipe que j'ai
emmené dans le qg restera avec moi et tu
sais mis en cause à cause de ce qui se
passera lors dé ce père en tout cas que
tu pourra retourner à new york dans des
restaurants pour recommencer à cuisiner
en antillais pour les new yorkais avec
tout ça ça va se régler très vite
est-ce que tu arrives à trouver aux
états unis tu nous parlais de fruit à
pain tout à l'heure est-ce que tu
arrives à trouver cessé mais particulier
qu'on retrouve surtout dans la caraïbe
et chez nous se trouve ce point que tout
je trouvais de la garrigue est plein de
choses tu imagines elle a trouvé ici
par contre la seule chose qui manque et
c'est avec la chose qui me fait mourir à
la personne de la et déjà connaissent
pas il va falloir qu'on te fasse un
petit colis pays qu'on va t'envoyer
rempli de bimont végétarien
dès qu'on pourra merci en tout cas mike
ont été ravis de partager ton expérience
qu'ont vécu siantou et puis on te
souhaite plein de bonnes choses soient
prudents bien sûr et puis on espère te
retrouver très vite dans d'autres
conditions dans son restaurant pour
faire le métier que tu aimes merci mike
s'était confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite à 18h45 sur martinique la
première
[Musique]